oh ho hoes in different area codes its
definition here this time I've got a Z
box from zabi
it is nineteen town normally but they
reduced the first box of ten pounds so I
thought I'd check it out
then she Kelly cancel it cancel that I'm
not paying twenty quid for this crap
open it
got another stormtrooper if you've been
watching me series every single time I
get a fungal box
it's a bloody storm trooper in it off
you go with eBay make you going straight
on that one t-shirt here I'm serenity
did really like serenity that much so
that can go on eBay as well
got a little Star Wars flats it's a
little trouble mug I tell you who the
mug is for buy a net hoodie mate so I
was little table ha I mean fair enough
if you want to if you want to tell
people you like Star Wars not round here
because he'll probably get beat you know
what about the said box exclusive hit or
know what that is it's got Tom Cruise in
so I mean you can't go wrong with that
so that'll be the last Jedi buy that box
that didn't make sense but that'll be
the last time I buy it was a very
unimpressed with that but you know a lot
of stuff to go on ebay I'll probably
make about five quid off it so thanks
very much I give that box a four out of
ten I'll see you next time take care
Pete